let's see if this works can you guys see
me and hear me i hope you can
um
so i'm here i'm luca as if some of you
know me or maybe all of you know me i'm
here in
poland
and um i want to make sure before we
start that you can actually hear me and
see me and i guess it's working uh this
is working properly i'm here with my
friend and colleague
berta who's going to help me is going to
moderate um also the
the live
you can ask questions in different
languages but if you ask them in english
it's going to be easier for me because
this one in particular this live is in
english
and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to
answer questions that some people ask me
directly on
uh instagram and other social uh you
know social media and also i'm gonna go
back and forth
to uh you know to
also questions that you're gonna help me
ask me here
um
so let's get started
and i'm gonna go back uh back up here to
see uh the first questions
uh but before i do that i'd like to
start with the instagram questions so
let me get my phone cause i'm gonna use
a combination of my phone and also my
computer
so i had i received a lot of interesting
questions especially on instagram and
let me go to instagram first so i'm
gonna address a couple of questions on
instagram and then i'm gonna come back
here and i'm going to try to answer as
many questions as possible you ask me a
lot of questions
um and we have more or less an hour an
hour 15 minutes
let's see but i can't switch more than
that so we have 75 minutes to you know
to have fun so let's get started without
further ado the first question here is
um
so let me see
i'm gonna go from top to bottom how did
you start to learn polish
speaking of polish i'm here in poland
what was the first thing what that you
did and what were the first things that
you have learned when did you start to
speak polish with people
the answer is i started using asimil as
i always do so i was in poland in uh in
2012 i think and then i decided to learn
polish and the very first thing that i
did is i got hold of a book called
asimil it had asimo in polish italian
and then i used decimal to get a
foundation of the of the language by
using my bi-directional translation
method um and also developed a course in
this regard
and then um i just started having
conversations with mikhail who was a
friend a friend i got to know in poznan
and then i just started using uh you
know these conversations with him and
joanna another
polish girl i met
in poland and then i started you know
developing polish little by little but
to answer your you know your question
thoroughly thoroughly it would take it
would take an hour but the bottom line
is if you want to start learning polish
or any other language get a very good
set of a good very good
language learning material to start with
get a solid foundation of in the
language and then you can start
venturing into the beautiful realm of
speaking with people or uh you know
enjoying authentic content
so that's the first
question let me see here
hi luke i'd like to know if you have any
recommendations holding the phone here
for advanced speakers who are struggling
with the rhythm speed of their speech
how can you get rid of pauses that a
native speaker wouldn't normally make in
the middle of a sentence or between
sentences my simple answer to that is
that if you want to improve the way you
talk you should slow down look at what
i'm doing right now i'm speaking in a
natural way but i am slowing down and
you have multiple factors
multiple features of your speech
patterns one of the most important ones
is without a doubt speed when you change
one of these factors and in particular
when you change the way the speed the
pace at which you talk you give your
mind
space to tweak a few things and be aware
of your patterns so that's the first
thing try to slow down a little bit when
you when you speak and try to get some
sort of develop some sort of awareness
of the way you express yourself one of
the best ways to do that is just to
engage in self-talk you can have
conversations with yourself you don't
have to talk to other people you can
record yourself you can listen to
yourself to see
uh the pauses that you make or maybe the
m's and um's which are inevitable in
in speech when you talk and then you can
even send this um
you know this recording to someone for
feedback and correction but you have to
start with awareness because if you
don't change something if you're not
aware of the way you talk if you don't
listen to yourself or watch yourself
speaking and if you don't take the time
to deliberately change patterns your
brain is automatically going to engage
in the same patterns and it's going to
be you know difficult to change
the the first thing that you need to
have the first the most important factor
is always awareness and willing to
change your patterns because the brain
is very good at learning but very
not very good at unloading things so
that's an important thing to take into
account
now let's go to some of these of the
questions here
i think julia asked a bunch of questions
related to pronunciation and and uh you
know speech as well
um
hello luca thank you for super helpful
content thank you so much and for being
an example of what's possible have you
heard of a voice analysis program called
pratt it's free to download widely used
bilinguals and apparently used in
forensics as well do you think it's
worthwhile to invest the time needed to
learn to use this program for accent
elimination for those who are not very
technologically inclined and my answer
is yes but that should be on top of
listening as much as you can so when i
talk about when when when you hear stuff
about acts and reduction getting your
pronunciation to a native-like level
getting a native-like accent i believe
that this the recipe is very simple you
have to listen to
the language as much as possible to
expose yourself to language as much as
possible that's the base
if you do that if you spend 30 40 30
minutes 45 60 minutes two hours watching
movies listening to podcasts and getting
exposed to the language in all possible
ways
then
you're going to develop good
you know pronunciation patterns
subconsciously but you also need some as
i said before you need to be aware of
some things unfortunately things are not
as easy
for us as adults learning a second
language as for kids learning their own
native language so listening and getting
exposed is the base and it's very
important so 30 to 60 minutes every
single day
being interested in what you hear and
trying to figure out the patterns but
then you have to do some work in order
to refine your pronunciation patterns
i've heard of pranat and in particular
there is an article i don't remember i
don't have the exact link but i might
find it you know
um
i might leave it on in the section
in the comment section once this live is
over because it's going to be on youtube
and there's specifically a method that
uses path very much in detail in order
to dissect the speech patterns of a
language to improve and i would say it's
a whatever you do which is like
deliberate where you identify the
patterns and you try to understand the
patterns deliberate is good on top
of everything else and if you think that
it's not worth your time you don't
necessarily need that uh i mean as kids
we have learned to pronounce our native
language perfectly without pat as adults
we can do the same without or without
these
with this very in-depth analysis but
it's possible it's not you have to think
whether this is something you want to
go for or not in my case for chinese i
invested
a lot of time in pronunciation because
from the from the get-go because i
thought it was important so you have to
you have to ask yourself is this so
important for me if this
spending time on this goes to the
detriment of actually learning the
language release and listening to the
language then it's not worth it so
here's my uh here's my answer think
about it if you know it takes you too
much time and too much energy
to set this up and then use it and it
goes to the detriment of actually using
the language listening to the language
etc then it's not worth it
vinicius sent in uh how do you review
your handwriting notes well this is a
long it's a it's a long um
it's a long answer it's a it would take
a long time but basically what i do is
that i use um i don't know if i have
them here actually i don't
i have now
these but these are for normal notes but
in general what i do is that i just jot
down my notes i make sure that whether i
listen to podcasts or watch videos
i make sure that i jot down
pieces of content that are grouped in
like they have a framework of reference
like for example if i watch easy greek
now now i'm
i'm learning greek
i write on top easy greek podcast number
30 and then i write the date that's my
framework of reference it's very
important for your episodic memory and
then i write a bunch of
not words but pieces of content that are
related to specifically that are
meaningful within the context of the
podcast or the video
and then i do this at the end of the
week for example if i watch a podcast if
i have listen if i listen to a podcast
say on tuesday that i make sure that at
the end of the week i jot down i
transfer i put all these um notes into
the notebook because the first time i
just listen to this podcast and i mark
words on the podcast then on saturday i
jot transfer all these pieces of content
into my notebook and then i review my
notebook the notes
for two minutes a day so the real deal
here and i had i saw another question
about srs so i'm gonna answer directly
um to that one as well someone asked me
how much time do you invest in srs
systems and is it worth it
my answer is
that the bulk of the work is in actually
choosing the pieces of content to review
but once that is done once they are in
these notebooks what i do is that i
review them a couple of minutes a day
two minutes a day randomly i know it's
counter-intuitive because a lot of
people spend a lot of time into srs and
they make lists of words i wouldn't go
so far as to say is that it's useless
but again if it goes to the detriment of
actually getting exposed to the language
then you sh you should spend
5
of your time if you're learning time
doing that not twenty percent not thirty
percent
and not fifty percent sorry i have to
drink a lot of water i've been talking
nonstop for 15 minutes
so
the bottom line is um
find a system that works for you i like
notebooks because they're you know you i
have
a better relationship with paper than
you know with the computer
and then make sure that you
review two five minutes a day so that's
really a little portion of your time it
should never go to the detriment of
actually using uh the language and
getting exposed to the language
so
these are the first questions here let
me ask let me answer a couple of other
questions here everybody see ya i'm
seeing look with the the stuff that you
wrote probably five five or ten minutes
ago
when i said look at them
said i can't wait
to start
um
christina
christina maylin i think from brazil i
would like to know if the bi-directional
translation method can be applied to
children learning a language i would say
depends on the age i think the
bi-directional
translation method is quite
straightforward i think you can use it
from say
maybe the age of eight nine
i think that from the
age of eight nine or ten you can use the
bi-directional translation without a
problem by the way the bi-directional
method or the bi-directional translation
for those who don't know uh is a method
that i have developed to
understand
for beginners to understand the
foundation to get a solid foundation of
the language and i also have a course on
that but we're going to talk about
courses at the end because i have an
announcement to make but that is for uh
you know for later
so uh
hi man
question how do i stop translating from
english to my target language i've been
studying intensively for 17 months and
still sometimes need to think in english
when listen when listening and speaking
i think we talked about this uh
in the forum jaime is one of my students
within the smart language learning
academy because now i have an online
school we're talk we're going to talk
about that in a little bit and we have
addressed this problem
when it comes to translating in your
head it's very it's a very common thing
that we tend to do when we s
when we listen or we speak
you know a foreign language i think that
the the problems are separate i would
say when it comes to listening make sure
that you just focus on trying to listen
to the entire sentence without having to
focus necessarily on the specific words
because what happens is that if you
listen to the language and you try to
pinpoint to understand every single word
since
natural speed natural speech is too fast
then you're gonna focus on that and then
you know that the guy that the person
speaking has already continued talking
and then you completely lose focus
so it's just like in a way observing the
river you have to let it wash over you
and you have to try to understand the
gist of
of a sentence you have to understand the
main key points and this requires a
little bit of training and you have to
resist the
you know the natural tendency of trying
to understand every single word because
that's not the way it works the more you
listen to
to the language uh the better or the
lesser the problem i would say
that you should get exposed to reading
and listening at the same time could
really help because by when you read and
listen at the same time you have to
focus much more this is for listening
and when it comes to um then speaking uh
the same thing is that
and i think you're already giving you
this advice on the form
of the school is that you have to try to
think
in a simple way so we all have the
tendency of wanting to sound like
refined native speakers of of a foreign
language without having the tools to do
that and my piece of advice is actually
to speak in simple sentences instead of
you know trying to save convoluted
sentences and that i learned the lesson
the hard way when i was trying to learn
you know japanese and i was trying to
form sentences with two clauses like for
example
um i want to go to japan because i've
never been there and it's a fascinating
country
that's fine i can say this in english or
italian or in any european language but
when it comes to japanese you have to
completely change the order and the
simpler the sentence the better so for
listening and for speaking you have
different strategies translation is a
common is a common tendency but you can
overcome it by re-training your brain to
simplify the way you talk and when it
comes to listening to focus on the
general sense instead of focusing on the
single words
that make out the the speech the speech
sound so to speak
um
so let me see here
mikko lesser kevin
so bernadette asks in hungarian when
we're going to have the next
live in spanish
let's see maybe in a couple of months i
will see
i love you thank you i love you i love
you too
so hello from spain um
okay let me go back to the questions as
i said i'm gonna do back and forth um
to the questions on instagram
so the language addict nice name said
i've been learning russian for a really
long time but i'm still stuck at an a2
level so what do you recommend me to do
to level up thank you in advance i have
the answer for you when i talk to you
about it
at the end of this video but to give you
a very short answer in this regard is
that you have to engage in the language
in a different way so
every three months i always advise my
students to assess the kind of the way
they have been learning so every three
months you stop and you just take some
time and think okay what is it that i'm
doing uh what are the activities that i
like what are the activities that i
don't like what are the activities that
i think are not pushing me forward or
not helping me move on what are the
activities that i want to discard what
are the ones i want to improve
and there's two different modes of
learning there's like simple as simple
mode what i call simple practice and
then you have purposeful practice and
then you have deliberate practice
actually there are three levels of
practice
and that
the the mode or
the way you practice is really really
important when it comes to getting
unstuck when you're stuck at a certain
level and you want to move to the next
one let me give you an example if for
example you've been listening to
podcasts and you've been listening to
podcasts um just listening to podcasts
you're let's say that you're a b1 level
and you're not improving then there
might be something that has to do with
podcast that is not working maybe the
podcast are at a lower level than your
current level so you should engage in
podcasts that have higher content and
when it comes to engaging with higher
like content that is more difficult more
challenging for your current level then
you have to engage it in purposeful or
deliberate practice so you have to take
steps
to undertake steps in order to
be more focused and make sure that you
spend um time like 30 minutes or 45
minutes very focused and trying to
dissect
uh text a transcript of a podcast or the
podcast itself by listening and reading
and reading and listening to it multiple
times marking words this is kind of
purposeful practice so you're engaging
with the content with the purpose of
improving from it while just watching a
video on youtube or listening to a
podcast that maybe you understand most
most of it is not gonna cut it as they
say so you have to refine and re-change
the way you're doing things in order to
move on to the next step
would take me extra hour to explain
everything you have to do in detail but
i'll talk to you about again
at the end of this video i'll talk about
something that i have
that could help you in that regard
about moving from a2 to b2
so
uh ph dash
what about your space repetition
strategy for me reps are so much time
consuming any advice thanks maestro
thank you thank you for calling me as to
always put smile on my face i'm not a
maestro but whatever
um
i already applied this question so i the
i i minimize the amount of time i do
space repetition because to me what
really counts is actually getting a
massive input and massive meaningful use
of the language or engagement with the
language so imagine learning a language
like a pyramid i call it the language
pyramid at the base is always input it
might sound counter-intuitive because
people tend to think oh in order to
speak the language i have to speak it
yes but you have to get massive input
and by massive input i mean
watching watching movies watching videos
listening to podcasts listening and
reading
as much as you can or even reading books
um you know engaging with podcasts as
much as you can because that's what is
going to take you to the next level
because you're going to start absorbing
the language
unconsciously or subconsciously and at
the beginning some 10 years ago i did
not believe in this theory but then i
have refined things and i've seen that
they act it actually
works much better than just you know
trying to speak as much as you can or
trying to engage in space repetition
uh practice that's okay but it should be
on top of the pyramid so input is the
base output second and then you have all
the grammar study srs
that should be five percent of your time
because it's time consuming it's energy
consuming and it's not as effective it's
not that effective if you don't have the
base and the base is always input which
is way easier to to do and uh you know
less stressful so to speak
let me go back to this beautiful
chat here um
i already got lost because i have to go
up there's so many questions guys i want
to say i'm gonna try to answer as many
as possible but unfortunately sometimes
um you know sometimes i miss
uh i miss some and that's that's okay
so
um
someone said your bi-direction
translation method is fire thank you so
much it works well and also we have more
than 300 actually happy students in the
academy so i'm very i'm very glad that
it's working uh well for them
cyrus does your intermediate language
class apply to any language learning i
want to have a good mastery of french
and cantonese yes it does i haven't
talked about the the course yet i'm
going to talk about it at the end but
but it does it applies to any language
of course
having said that it's important to
stress that
you can have the you know the the
overall strategy always works and
applies to any language but then you
have to change according to the language
so if say you're a native english
speaker the way you you might approach
french and cantonese the techniques and
the general way of learning is very
similar but then you have to do
different things a few different things
because the languages are kind of
different so for cantonese you might
want to
just to give an example work especially
on
pronunciation from the get-go because i
think they have nine tones or something
like that seven nine i think it's nine
tones
some some somebody said there's actually
six but regardless of that
the the general way of doing things is
exactly the same so it's a class that
applies to any language in the world but
then you have different
different a few different things you
have to change depending on the language
so
let's see here
i am learning this is
h n b r g i'm learning russian and i
struggle a lot with the cases especially
when speaking i seem to forget all the
rules i've memorized and it more or less
turns into a guessing game any tips yes
i do
uh have some tips for you h and b r g
and my tip is that
my advice in this regard is that
if you think about grammar structures
when you talk and you try to communicate
then it gets in the way you stephen
krashen talks about this this is called
the monitor hypothesis for those who
have learned about this i've heard about
this but basically in your mind you have
two systems you have a assist two memory
systems so to speak so you have um
you know we have declarative memory you
have procedural memory procedural memory
is the memory that helps you talk
uh that helps you engage in skills like
speaking your own native language or
swimming or doing something naturally so
you do something it's called procedural
because it's a procedure the entire
procedure that you can't explain so it's
difficult to explain why you're riding a
bike you just ride a bike you just speak
your native language one word
you know just follows the other
well declarative memory has to do with
the things that you can actually declare
you can state for example uh words if i
say dog do you know the word dog in
spanish or japanese then you can say it
right and
grammar rules so
like
the the grammar rules stating the
grammar rule how a grammar rule works
you can say it you can understand it but
using it in natural speech is a
different matter so one thing is
studying grammar rules another thing is
integrating them into speech and if you
think about cases and grammar rules when
you talk in in russian it's in russian
or any other language it literally gets
in the way it burdens your or your your
memory and it keeps you from speaking
naturally
my advice is to get as much input as
possible don't worry too much about
getting the case right just speak and
focus on
communication
don't focus on form
so that's a really important thing
because if you think too much about
grammar it actually gets in the way i
know it's counterintuitive but the best
way to do this is to get as much input
as possible because a huge chunk of the
structures of the language your brain is
going to figure them out if you feed it
the right piece of information if you if
you don't get enough input and you try
to force output that's exact and you
think about grammar
you just get tongue-tied because you
constantly think about you have to get
things right and it gets in the way
focus on communication this is a big
mind mindset shift that has to happen
but it takes some time you know i i know
a lot of people think about grammar
stuff or they want to sound perfect and
they focus too much on form instead of
meaning remember this focus on meaning
and not
form and get a lot of massive input
so
let's see
um
hi luke i really like your american
accent teddy salcido greetings from
mexico thank you thank you so much
um
let me see here
uh reggie cadder
i hope i didn't mispronounce your name
reggie one more are you familiar one
more you probably ask a question
somewhere i can't see it
are you familiar with the sla
i guess a second language acquisition
research that exists for example the
famous
morpheme study stephen krashen was
involved with if so what do you think of
the development developmental
stages as described
um i have been
i've been delving into linguistics
recently especially second language
acquisition i've been reading a lot
about crashing and not only crashing i
don't know about the famous morpheme
studies but i um
will publish probably in 2022 a full
review of one of the books
i i don't have it here i think i have it
in crackle a left and in krakow
one of uh the books
that stephen krashen wrote and his work
and i think that i agree with pretty
much 85 85-90
of what he says
uh now i don't know about the more of
the famous morpheme studies but i can
tell you that
what crashan says really hits the nail
on the head as they say and i've been
doing a lot of thinking about the way i
learn languages and why
i managed to learn so many languages
successfully and it's because
i do most of what stephen steve says a
student should do i've developed this
naturally and the funny thing is that i
did it outside of the school system if i
had listened to what people say and how
they learn languages at school that
would have slowed me down big time but
to answer your question is yes i love
second language acquisition i have a
bunch of books at home i've been delving
into crashing specifically but then you
have a few other linguists that
are really interesting to to you know
to listen to
so
um
cadence uh my question is when do you
stop shadowing a language uh my answer
won't you start shadowing your language
i usually deal with the beginning stage
without asimo do you ever return to it
as an advanced learner cheers from
canada i don't do shadowing i got to
tell you the truth i do something a
little bit different
it's a little bit long to explain but i
kind of listen to the text and i mark it
with my own markers and then i read it
but i don't follow a person speaking so
i just listen to them multiple times and
then i
read the text according to my own
markings but if you like shadowing um
just by all means go for it and
i i think that it it's helpful to get
the language out there and to start
producing sounds you know
um
italo do you think it's better for
note-taking to use a digital software
including screenshots of a video auto
pieces and stuff i would say go like if
you want to use uh digital then go go
all digital i've been doing this because
i've been traveling and i'm gonna go to
hungary next so unfortunately i cannot
have so much paper and i have fun also
with the digital uh you know writing
marking things jotting things down the
truth is paper for me is better and
according to research if you write paper
versus screen you will see the paper and
engaging also especially writing it
develops your motor memory it's way
better to remember vocabulary than just
screen but you can you can just decide
and and and do whatever whatever
whatever flows your boat as they say
um adrian asks a very interesting
question what's your opinion on
listening and reading of the same
language uh at the same time some people
swear by and others say you'll be too
focused on text to actually listen
properly if you learn to do it well
that's one of the best techniques and i
always do it all the time that is
listen and read at the same time why
because if you listen and read at the
same time you will understand the text
you will hear uh what like how the
language is pronounced and you will
focus
and i don't believe uh you know the
theory that people actually say you
should go just listen to the language
because if you read it then you're going
to get confused because it's another way
of writing things the brain will
naturally sound map create a you know
sound mapping creates a correspondence
between the way the language is spoken
and the way a language is written in a
very natural way that's a one of the
actually the very first thing that i do
is listen and read and i think it's the
best simplest way to get
inside you know to to understand the
basic uh structures of the language and
i still do it engage
in it during the intermediate phase then
one once your understanding of the
language gets really good then you can
just listen to the language
so um
so let me see here um
glad to see you again sophia thank you
glad to see you well i can't see you but
um
[Music]
that is reminding you to write only in
english this is a q a in english she's
pretty strict
so
um
[Music]
pp i think also is also student of the
academy and what in what stage of
language learning we stop translating in
our head the native language to target
language is there any way to expedite to
reach the level it causes awkward gaps
while speaking at least for me i think i
think you're pradeek
if i'm not wrong pb
uh
and
the answer is i just said it like some
20 minutes ago i think that it's
inevitable to do some translating in
your head but i think that what you
should do is to get as much input as
possible and with months and years
you're going to get better and better i
know that you know some people want to
say i just want to talk speak the
language fluently as soon as possible
but what normally happens when people
tend to translate a lot in their head is
that they haven't gotten enough input
think about a kid getting years and
years of input that's what counts then
once you get the input you can start
actually developing naturally developing
the structures without translating too
much in your head so um i think the best
the best way to do it is just to get as
much input as possible and to sim as i
said before if you have you know for
some reason missed that is to think in
simple terms think about a
a piece of
of information that you want to deliver
to your interlocutor and then think
about the simplest possible way to
deliver it maybe in chunks it's going to
help you to avoid translating in your
head try it like think about something
that you currently
maybe record yourself look at the
patterns that you use and then simplify
those patterns it's a really interesting
exercise to see how can i say this in a
simpler way
so um
the polyglot dude nice name apart from
massimo have you found any other great
beginner resources especially for less
common languages i used
uh teach yourself and i found it okay
but sassimo is way better and it depends
on the language i found some resources
for chinese some resources for japanese
but normally i use asimo and if i can't
use asmo i do i create my own asthma by
asking friends to create my own version
like i did for example for serbian
so
nick uh is from the phonetic analysis in
the bi-directional translation still
necessary for european languages like
polish we have a lot of students from
the academy so they're asking specific
questions i have to give you the
background the the by drag by the
reaction translation method has many um
phases or many steps and the second of
you know in order to dissect a text or a
piece of content the second one is
called phonetic analysis and yes i would
definitely say the phonetic analysis is
not necessary
for any language because it's a method
that allows you to focus more on the
patterns and to be more aware of how
this the sound patterns of a language
unfold so i would say yes it's true that
polish is a regular language you have
that the stress always on the first
syllable but that doesn't mean a thing
you know it's just
the fact that you're listening and
reading and marking things is going to
help you see the patterns that you
especially at the beginning are
important to see in order to develop
good pronunciation
let me go back to some of these
questions here i could stay here forever
guys but unfortunately i can't answer
all the questions how do you learn
chinese this is a good one
well as i said i used asimu
to make a very long as a story short
very short as i i just grabbed asimil so
asimo is this french
french book i have i had chinese and
italian texts i had two tomes they call
them or books
um
and i just went i did my i applied the
bi-directional translation to it back
and forth for around three months the
first one and then three months the
second one and then i got myself a very
nice book i don't remember the name now
i don't i'm not in rome so otherwise i
would show you and then i started doing
that one which had a lot of longer texts
and then i used link basically
i think most of you already know steve
kaufman that talks about link that's uh
what he created and i massively used
link to listen and read to podcasts and
dissect him podcast and spend hours and
hours doing that and i got to a decent
level so that's what i did for input
then i started talking in a forum where
you could actually talk to people back
then you could you there were chats i
don't remember the name of it now
it was sponsored by rosetta stone but it
was taken down i'm pretty sure some of
you know that i had a lot of time talk i
had a fantastic time talking to chinese
people
and then unfortunately
i stopped doing that and i haven't
i haven't spoken chinese in a long time
chinese and japanese are languages that
are suffering a little bit because
inevitably it's different it's difficult
to maintain 14 or 15 languages
so
uh italian look have you ever relearned
a language to get an accent from another
region that you preferred no i've never
done that um but i have fun sometimes
with my friends speaking in different
you know accents for example in english
speaking with a scottish accent or an
irish accent or a british accent or
other and an italian and i do all the
accents from the north to the south i
haven't done this on youtube yet but i
upon request i i could
so
let me see here um
how you don't confuse spanish and
italian when it comes to speaking felipe
says i can understand almost everything
in italian but once in a blue moon i get
confused it depends on how you learn the
languages if you're a brazilian i guess
from your name i'm not sure learning
italian and spanish it really depends on
when you learn and how you learn that
for me i'm a native italian speaker so
it's not a problem at all i'm not
dealing with two
similar foreign languages i'm just
dealing with one foreign language that
is similar to mine
and again to answer your question it
really depends on how you use the
languages i might
my simple piece of advice is just to
get exposure to both languages on a
daily basis so that your brain knows
that both are kind of impo both are
equally important because if you don't
do that if one if you start speaking one
much more than the other then another
you know it
one take takes over so to speak and you
start confusing the languages it's a
little bit it's a little bit complicated
explain this uh because
timing the language your native language
the target languages
how similar they are they all play a
role in
the confusion in the way you confuse
them so to speak
so
juan torres how is it to be a language
coach and how can we become one
greetings from colombia it feels great
i've been working as a language coach
over the last 11 years and i just you
know i can tell you the way i became a
language coach it just created a youtube
channel and then people started
following me and then i just started
saying hey i'm i'm a language coach i
teach people i started teaching and then
i started i realized that coaching was
what was much more powerful than just
teaching the language to someone because
you can't teach a language to anybody
but you can show them the way
and in order to become a coach there are
organizations that allow you you know if
you look for a language coach you have
to
subscribe and they have to follow a
course and then you can become a
certified language coach but my my
suggestion is just do it in your own way
just if you want to become a coach you
have to create your own channel you have
to create your own space and on the
internet and then you have to start
um
this is still in the making but one day
not so far in the future
there might be something in this regard
as well can reveal anything but you know
something that i've been thinking about
about helping people become language
coaches
so um
let me see here
uh
let me see
let me go back to the questions here for
a second
how do you learn chinese i replied are
there any correspondence of the numerous
grammatical cases of hungarian to
romance languages and never thought
about that but you know this is they say
when it comes to translation when it
comes to comparing languages you have to
know
you know every language has a way of
expressing something i wouldn't worry so
much about hungarian
cases i've been hearing so much about
russian has seven cases polish has seven
cases hungarian is 18 finnish is 25 or i
don't remember it's irrelevant
irrelevant when i are in front of it
it's not relevant we tend to think fret
too much about the number of cases but
the reality is that even you know the
dumbest native speaker can use them on a
daily basis they don't use all of them
to use just a small portion of them and
you have to use them you have to learn
them naturally the brain is very
powerful indeed so instead of focusing
on 18
cases which is discouraging just get um
you know exposure to the language get
exposure to interesting compelling
understandable comprehensible content
and the brain will do a big chunk not
all of it unfortunately but do a big
chunk be aware make sure that you get
interested in understanding the few
grammar points that you might not
understand don't engage too much in
grammar studies because it goes to the
detriment of actually learning the
language and absorbing the language in a
natural way and the brain will do the
rest forget about the 18 cases or 7 or 9
or whatever it is
gemma
when is your intermediate course coming
out um i will talk about about this it's
already come out we still have a
promotion for
24 hours but i will talk about this in a
second uh but it came out and i think
you already purchased the curse actually
so
let me see here uh what are the
differences between serbian and slavic
languages that you already speak this is
still alison alison dc
basically it serbian is very very
similar to russian
from my perspective i know russian and
polish it really helped
no problem there no
no
no big things that you know i said oh my
god this is so different just the the
way they use modal verbs to say i have
done they say i am done or they always
use the m always used to be for modal uh
you know for expressing i have done this
i have gone et cetera et cetera in
english you just have have any time you
have have and to be in other languages
as well but that's the only thing
basically the rest is pretty
straightforward maybe the other feature
is that the accent moves or the the
stress moves for example in polish in
hungarian it's always on the first
syllable the stress in serbian it moves
and maybe that's that's that makes it a
little bit more complicated but from
someone who already knows two slaving
languages serbian is pretty
straightforward
when it comes to speaking it's a
different matter i've been learning for
six months
and
i'm basically
engaged in input but i'm i'm just loving
it
most awkward experience in a foreign
language jonathan
i but there's so many so i i can't i
can't pick one but the bottom line is
that
when it comes to
learning a foreign language you have to
get your fair share of discomfort and
embarrassing situations and mind you
there's been a lot of them maybe one
that i remember like was i already
talked about this somewhere in the q a
was when i was in hungary budapest and
i'm going there in just 10 days i'm
pretty excited
is when i wanted to buy a ticket the
station and i went there and there was
this grumpy lady you know
i think i found such a
a level of grumpiness just in russia and
in hungary so she was sitting there she
was looking mean and she was actually
mean and and i just try to blurt
something because i had been learning
the language for i don't know
eight months
and i was already not very
sure about what i wanted to say and then
it turned into a disaster because the
lady was not helping at all and then at
the end we managed to get the ticket but
it was kind of awkward you know
but you again the bottom line is that if
you don't get out there and you get your
fair share of embarrassment situations
so the awkward situations you're never
going to grow and this doesn't only go
for languages but goes
for life in general for every single
language i've learned i have a few
embarrassing moments or awkward moments
or situations i had to go through and
after that i felt relieved and i said
i'm stronger than i was before i can
face anything if i can face this and i
can survive this i can make it anywhere
and i i can survive any other situation
so um
how long did it take you to learn
chinese this is always about chinese
there's a lot of people interested in
chinese now it took me around two years
to start speaking the language decently
let's put it this way then learning a
language and the concept of learning a
language it would take me two hours to
explain but basically it takes me around
two years of hard work to get to start
enjoying the language let's put it this
way then you have franklin but this is
um this is like a three page long
question so i'm going to skip that sorry
franklin next time
uh
nestorovich
been the most difficult part in learning
serbian i already replied to that
question
i um we have to go and finish one day
and he says in in in hungarian it's
almost uh as difficult as uh hungarian i
believe so we had a nice conversation
with stefano you know stefano from
lingue pasione we talked about finnish
and hungarian he wants to learn
uh hungarian i want to learn finnish one
day maybe let let's see i still don't
know
um
marco butka i guess german uh it reminds
me it rings a bell how do i reinforce
words into my head when they lose their
high frequency the better i become the
more rare are the words that i need and
i'm having a bit trouble of trouble with
that i think you shouldn't worry about
that because war
the vocabulary in general vocabulary
acquisition has a specific curve we
learn the majority of the words let's
say that
the most common words and then
and then for the words that are common
it's more difficult to learn because
we're gonna come across them less
less often and i wouldn't worry so much
about that what i would do what i would
say though is that i would engage in
massive reading
extensive reading marking words you will
see them again you will forget you will
see them again until they get stuck i
wouldn't worry too much about high level
vocabulary because it's the kind of
vocabulary that is more difficult to
stick i would just focus on enjoying the
language and reading as much as you can
reading has changed my life not only
like my life in general but language
learning if you want to take it to the
next level you have to read and you have
to read a lot and link vocabulary
acquisition will be a consequence of
that
so
let me see here um
[Music]
hi luca is knowing all the vocabulary
from english vocabulary in use advanced
enough to claim that i have seen one
level in terms of vocabulary and do you
know any other resources for advanced
vocab i think that that
i as i said before you shouldn't fret
and worry too much about the the extent
uh the extents the extents would you say
the um amplitude of your vocabulary will
really counts instead of thinking oh am
i advanced enough do i know 10 000 words
20 000 words it's completely irrelevant
what you should engage in is massive
reading and reading stuff that is
interesting for you the accounting of
the vocab vocabulary or the amount of
words that you know is just a
distraction
the skill the the
the let's say the skills the language
skills that you develop do have to do
with vocabulary in part and vocabulary
is important but there's so much more to
it that meets the eye as this as they
say so don't worry too much about the
how big your vocabulary actually is
focus on reading and exposing your
yourself to the language as much as you
can this would be my answer
uh joe ciao vista in polonia polygon
gathering
city
i saw you at the gathering i don't
remember joe we probably met i don't
remember but we had fun that was pretty
cool the polygon gathering if you guys
ever
want to participate you don't need to be
a polyglot polygon gathering in europe
and polygon conference in
in mexico in october just type polygon
conference it's a pretty cool event
so let me go down here
um
izak luka you should learn
oh you can see kenya vanda a language
for rwanda i've been thinking about
learning uh an african language let's
see what happens still don't know
but maybe in the next within the next 10
years i might
go for one african language um
so
um
let me see here
uh
dear carla do you have any specific
techniques for dealing with a block
moment when you panic
whilst listening to a native which
occurs simply because you're
anxious about not understanding
well it this is a problem that concerns
everyone right like when it comes to
speaking we're terrorized about sounding
dumb about not understanding people this
has been what like the one thing that
concerns me all the time and especially
when it comes to interactions with shops
that's why i don't like interacting with
people in shops that they throw at you
these like short sentences like for
example you go and say uh hey can you
know i'd like to buy this and then the
guy or the girl says
and you go like oh [ __ ] what what what'd
he say what did she say you know and
just you panic
so um i think that the best way to deal
with that is to get out of your comfort
zone and and whenever you put yourself
in situations where you actually
feel the discomfort and when you feel
the discomfort smile and say i do not
understand people are much more
understanding
than you think and all the fears are in
your head i think i saw recently a ted
talk about someone who i don't remember
exactly the name but who went through
10 or no 100
uncomfortable situations like i don't
know um asking someone to do something
on the street and they turn you down so
he he just got rejection 100 times he
got used to it now here we're not
talking about rejections but we're
talking about getting out of your
comfort zone so what i mean is that
not understanding is going to be part of
the process sometimes someone speaks
much faster than you expect sometimes it
says things that you don't know about
sometimes they use words that you don't
know it's just the art of facing the
unknown
with a big smile on your face and when
you do that you will see that actually
things are not as difficult as they look
if you approach a conversation
constantly thinking oh my god i'm not
gonna understand anything i'm gonna
freeze then you're gonna freeze you know
instead
if you go out there and you test it and
you say well okay let's have a plan b if
i don't understand i'm just gonna smile
and say can you repeat it please or just
smile and just say sorry i don't
understand
and that's natural that happens people
know that you're a foreigner trying to
learn their language they will
appreciate that they will appreciate
honesty much more than you think
so
monica
what advice do you have for turning a
language learning passion into a career
i'm a recent college graduate
languages and taught english overseas
thank you for the amazing content thank
you monica from his words i would say
get a blog or youtube get out there and
do it your own thing don't if you want
to go to institutions you can but i
wouldn't follow that round if you really
are passionate about
um about language learning and about
getting a career i think that and
nowadays we have the tools and the
possibilities of actually getting out
there and forming our own
doing our own stuff as i did it's more
difficult there's more um you know there
are more people around so it's more
difficult to stand out but if you
create a niche in which you're going to
operate i don't know learning a specific
language for specific native speakers
and you keep working on that you can
found you it's amazing the things you
can actually accomplish with a youtube
channel and you get visibility and then
you can start doing your own thing
and that's the kind of route that i will
go instead of just trying to go to an
institution and getting some sort of
master degree and working within the
system so to speak
luca do you consider that shank the
listening is the most important part of
language learning can one reach a high
level just by a lot of listening i would
say that's one of the most important
things and but and no if you want to
reach a solid level in for language you
have to engage in reading listening
listening and reading watching movies
with subtitles speaking with people and
even writing but speaking is the e
actually listening is the easiest thing
you can do because you can do it like
everywhere it's easy to do and it's one
of the most important activities
remember the language pyramid it should
be at the base listening to at least 30
minutes a day and then do other things
but i wouldn't just listen to the
language and just do that you have to do
many things in order to develop the
skills in a foreign language depending
on the skills you want to develop if you
just want to develop perfect listening
uh skills that's fine you can just
listen
but if you want to speak read and write
then you have to do those things as well
so
um
juan do you think that anki the anki app
is a good tool to improve vocabulary it
is you can use it if you like it i've
never used it i use notebooks and i do
it five percent of my time space
repetition the bulk of my time is spent
listening reading reading and listening
watching and and reading books that's
what i do so i repeat the bulk of my
time when it comes to the intermediate
learning especially is
listen
listen and read at the same time so i'm
talking about podcasts specifically and
then do a combination of these in
multiple steps then engaging with
watching videos watching videos with
subtitles without subtitles and then
reading first articles and short texts
and then books that's what really makes
a difference and that's the bulk of my
learning time and then of course engage
also in speaking and writing but that's
on top the top of the pyramid where is
the language pyramid kimberly says the
language pyramid is in my head and it's
also in the the courses that i you know
the one specific course i'm going to
talk about it at the end in a little bit
uh we explain
in detail how to dissect a language
parent how this works and how to
revolutionize your learning because
normally the pyramid the way people
approach language learning is on is the
opposite it's just they they spend a lot
of time studying doing space repetition
or doing grammar rules and they spend
little times in actually getting massive
input to meaningful comprehensible and
interesting content
that's surprising but people do things
the opposite way and they expect great
results which is
why i think we are very much in need of
a language learning revolution
so
uh let me see here
eric nowadays there's a lot of people
making a case for learning a language on
our own that's the best way to learn if
that's the case what would be the role
for all of us uh language teachers i
think that
i think that you can never really learn
a language by yourself
what i mean is that all the languages i
learned or languages i started learning
by myself but all the native speakers i
met are my teachers they have taught me
something i see them as a teachers a
teacher is a great
way to get things to the next level so
teachers are not useless actually
they're very useful what i'm just trying
to say that if you want to learn a
language well you can do 80 87 80 of
your
you know of your learning could come
from outside of the class and then when
you do that when you are in class when
you are in a class and you can interact
with the teacher
then things get can get even better
that's what happened to me at school
with english and french and i think uh
um i always
cherished and appreciated
especially my french teachers were which
who were amazing so there will always be
a
need for teachers always and um if
on top of my becoming an independent
student you have a fantastic teacher as
i did for english private teacher and
for french at
public school all the better so i'm not
against teaching at all actually a
teacher should set should actually
facilitate the
the learning process and sir robinson i
don't know if you ever heard of sir
robinson has fantastic ted talks about
that about education he passed away
unfortunately but you should definitely
watch it's also on youtube
i think it's sir robinson about
creativity about school and about
education in general
so
um
miguel uh
i had read oh thank you so much for the
words that just said you're encouraging
me a lot to keep my journey learning uh
language thank you miguel i don't know
exactly what your words are referring to
but i'm glad that they had a positive
impact to you
um how to be motivated to complete
learning a language well rene you don't
complete learning a language
meaning that you never stop learning and
it's not a matter of motivation it's a
matter of actually setting things up so
that you get motivated motivation
the concept of motivation is really a
big misunderstanding people tend to
think oh you know every day i have to i
get i get up and then i have to be
motivated to learn a language no you
have to know exactly why you want to
learn a language and you have to set up
systems so that you don't have to rely
on motivation you have to rely on
actually discipline that's a different
concept
so
first understand why you want to learn a
language and it has to be a really
compelling reason because if you don't
have enough compelling reasons you're
not gonna keep learning a language
because learning a language takes years
you might found some youtubers saying
that they can learn a language in three
days or three weeks or three months but
learning a language for real takes years
no matter the language remember that
keep that in mind because it's a long
journey if you're not motivated enough
and by motivating i mean setting up the
right system that provides motivation so
you don't have to find motivation
yourself every day but it just the
system provides it then you're in for a
long journey
but it's an exciting one
so um
gary lawrence has a very interesting
question look i haven't learned german
and russian before hungarian did it help
in learning hungarian vocab
not that much but i think that the fact
that
you know i've learned other languages
helped me in designing learning quickly
how to design a strategy to learn um
hungarian or any other language so not
necessarily like russian and german
the the fact that i learned these
languages helped me because i gained
experience in learning how to face the
different features that certain
languages have because certain
different languages pose different
problems
and hungarian poses its own different
you know problems let's put it this way
um
um hi look i just tuned in and was
wondering what your thoughts on talking
to yourself in your target language i
lost it here now i don't know why i just
um i think it's great i talk to myself
all the time and i use a specific
technique to talk to myself so in the
past i just talked to myself for the
sake of talking to myself now i have
precise criteria and i use my notebooks
i just take some stuff that i have
jotted down for podcasts or for vocab
sorry for for videos and then i talk to
myself
making a summary of that content in a
specific way can't go into the details
unfortunately uh because we don't have
time but i do talk about it in length in
uh one of
in the in the newest course that just
came out and which i will talk about
just in 10 minutes we still have around
15 minutes and then i have to rush
i have to go away unfortunately i would
stay here the whole day
um
so um
since you speak 14 languages are able to
recognize most people's accent to know
where they come from or what their
native language is most of the time i
can i can figure out
like you know most european languages
today for example i was in zara and
there a guy was speaking a language i
didn't i probably european maybe maltese
but i didn't know what that was so it
happens most of the time but not all the
time and as for access it depends if i
know a language well enough to
detect a different accent yes but for
languages like polish and russian it's
difficult because they there's not a lot
of accent varieties so a person from
wooch or a person from varshava were so
they kind of speak the same or from
krakow while in italy or other countries
like great britain in well you know
france spain you can tell there's
there's a lot of difference between an
accent from accents from the south and
actually from the north or the center so
i do recognize most of the languages
like especially if it's language's
accents it really depends on language
but in general yes i i
i kind of have fun with that year's
eavesdropping you know
so
are you thinking about venturing into
middle eastern languages like arabic
persian and hebrew gabriel lawrence asks
yes i do with
in due course i will do that uh maybe a
couple of years now i'm focusing on
hungarian greek and serbian and then
maybe the next one is going to be
turkish or hebrew let's see what happens
uh agree a good teacher is fantastic to
have you're teaching it right now thank
you mr imperfect um let me see here
how to get
the most of my conversations with my
friends when i speak with them in their
language uh young it might sound strange
but if you pay attention and you get a
a notebook and you say hey guys on and
off your mind if i jot down notes you're
gonna reap a lot of benefits out of
those conversations and that's what i do
all the time you know so
um i would do that um kathrina hi luca
do you believe your accent in english
has improved from when you started
learning it i think so and that's due to
the fact that i've been getting a lot of
massive input and i think that
subconsciously
it changed the way i speak and also i've
been doing more research into
american english pronunciation having to
teach it and if i watch
if i watch my videos of 10 years ago i
can clearly tell i had an accent there
i'm not saying that i speak like a
native speaker in english in american
english i'm just saying that i can
clearly tell
that i had an accent for a number of
reasons maybe i was stressing the the
wrong word
or i i you know it's just amazing what
massive input to a language massive
meaningful use can do to your brain
without you even wanting it it's just
the way it happened and the same thing
happened with french
and even with spanish
mario how to keep fluency in 10
languages that's a big one well you just
have to make languages part of your
daily life and there's a lot of
strategies to do that i was i am
fortunate enough that i'm able to do
that i
let's say that
i can normally on on a bad days i use
four languages on a good day i use 10 or
11
but use i mean listening or speaking and
using the language to have conversations
with my friends but it's really really
difficult in fact i have 15 languages
under my belt so to speak but that's
actually not correct i've been learning
15 languages and i speak i think 10 of
them fluent fluently depending on you
know
what you mean by fluent but it's really
a struggle to keep them up or to
maintain them because it requires an
incredible amount of time and energy to
be able to especially when it comes to
speaking listening comprehension is a
different matter listening comprehension
is for life once you understand a
language at a native level it never goes
away you can even not listen to a
language for 30 years you will still
understand it after 30 years speaking
just degrades very quickly unfortunately
output stuff output skills to grade very
quickly
so
um i think um
uh speak english with this guy you're
super close to a native speaker to a
native english speaker in the us thank
you um i don't know exactly
again i thought i sounded like a native
ten years ago and i was a little bit
cocky about that i thought okay do
something like no and then it figured
out no there's a lot of things for which
i clearly do not sound like a native it
doesn't matter but perfection is not the
goal uh for me the most important thing
is to actually keep improving and keep
the curiosity you know i like thinking
that
i recently read a very interesting book
about losing the curiosity that makes
the world wonderful as kids the student
of mine said that having a kid was is an
amazing experience because you can see
the world again with new eyes something
we have lost right when we become adults
and we give things for granted and i
think that keeping curio the curiosity
to keep exploring and to keep improving
is what really counts and it doesn't
matter if i sound like a native or
almost like a native it's just
i'm
clearly enjoying the right of speaking
english learning english communicating
in english and any other language
so um
i think we have
five
five ten more minutes and then i really
have to go unfortunately
um
so you must have a podcast and talk also
about books it's in the in the making
doors in 2023 we will talk about that
uh we will i will develop probably uh i
will
get into a podcast series and a book and
a lot of
other things um you know
um
because
it's about time so
but the bulk of this year we i've been
i've been dedicating it to as you as you
as you probably know i'm not you know i
haven't done a lot of
youtube videos recently because i've
been spending the bulk of my time in
creating courses and developing my
academy which is what i'm going to talk
about now
um
so
i'm going to just reply to a couple of
more questions and then we're going to
talk about this and then i'll let you go
guys i'm going to talk about the school
and the courses
why serbian lenka says because i like
serbia i was there i love the people and
i love the history of the balkans and so
i want to learn the language
um
so
um
can you recommend podcasts to train
english listening i think i have we have
a bunch of resources in the in the blog
if you look uh you should find a lot of
of things otherwise you can write
directly through the blog and i will
send you a few
and
and that's it guys so
um
we still have five minutes i just wanted
to tell you thank you so much for coming
for asking such interesting questions
the last thing i wanted to say as i was
saying before
is that
um
we have i'm very proud of uh of my team
we've been working for a few months uh
on creating a course for intermediate
learners something that people had asked
me before look at when are you gonna do
an inter course for um you know reaching
fluency a lot of people have been asking
me how do you reach phones how do you
overcome the intermediate pluto so
that's what we did and uh basically in
this course that came out two days ago
um i've put all the techniques all the
stuff that i talk about here
unfortunately i don't have the time to
develop and speaking details are all
there it's a huge course that we created
and um basically
um i'm
there's an entire community so we're
building a community we're also
building language spaces
um and um i think beta can leave
if you guys were interested berta will
my my colleague beth will leave um a
link
in the in the chat and then i'll leave
a comment and i will pin it so you can
see it in the comment section
once this live is over
you can basically
um you know
check the information about the course
and also about the academy in general so
the the most important thing for me and
the the reason why i'm proud
is because the academy and what we have
built is something that deals with
learning how to learn i believe that if
you understand learning how to learn
that's the most precious skill that we
have nowadays you understand
how to use your brain you can accomplish
a lot of stuff i believe that the system
um unfortunately the the way the
educational system is built
uh is inefficient
and um i
this is what pushes me this is what
drives me this is what makes me
passionate is just to
help people fulfill their language
dreams specifically because we're
talking about language learning and um i
i keep repeating this this is not about
a matter of being a genius i speak 15
languages because i put in the work but
most of all because i figured out how to
do it and you can do it as well and it's
not trivial it's something that it's
just proof all the people were like been
you know
coming to the academy we've been working
within the academy we had a conversation
just an hour ago students of the the
intermediate course the live course that
we did last year and it's amazing the
mind shift that they felt like oh i
thought all of the stuff before these
limiting beliefs now i can do this and i
believe that this is really what makes a
difference once you start seeing that
you can do stuff if you do things the
right way then it will change the way
you perceive yourself the world and of
course
language learning thank you so much for
coming
and uh i will see you soon i think the
next one is probably going to be in a
month or in a month and a half and then
we're probably going to do one more in
spanish it's been amazing um
you know thank you so much for all the
interesting questions the enthusiasm and
all the rest
and uh
and uh we will speak we will speak soon
again if you're interested in taking a
look at the latest course and also the
bdt we have the bi-directional
translation now for beginners and we
have the intermediate overcoming the
intermediate plateau for people who have
an a2 in a language b1 or a little bit
confused about how to go they're a
little bit stuck they're a little bit
lost and they want to reach fluency in
any language we have
that course now as well so we're very
proud that we made it happen two days
ago we published it and then it's gonna
be for it's gotta be available from now
on so just if you wanna check it
it's available
thank you so much and again have a
fantastic weekend and i will talk to you
soon keep rocking and happy language
learning as always
bye